i don't remember the last time i drank
11 beers because that's usually what
happens after 10.
what happened to you last time you drank
11 beers i quit
in the drinking of the fridge
i don't really drink here right but
so no wine red wine though but you're
off the wings until the wedding look out
i'm off the wine so that's the song
right there you guys should write that
awesome
[Laughter]
and the wreck laws know a thing or two
about riding hits jen and stu just
celebrated another milestone thanks to
their tracks
[Applause]
[Music]
tenth gold single tenth goal single
that's crazy that song was literally
written about frustration and we put it
on tick tock is almost kind of something
called what the truck yeah it was a bit
of a joke from the start and everybody
like immediately was like this is very
different and very cool and
the fans made it what it is
[Music]
you don't want to miss out on an
opportunity so all of this like all of
the golds have been amazing and we're
just so excited to have this new song
out as well
it's both introduced elves music and
they said y'all wanted to do a song
and
the song was super cool and i just
thought it fit the stories you tell in
your songs really line up with the
stories that we tell in ourselves yeah
especially with you because we've
literally been listening to you since we
were kids well that makes me feel great